here you hear you hear you all persons
are commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment while the Senate of the
United States is sitting for the trial
of the articles of impeachment exhibited
by the House of Representatives against
Donald John Trump President of the
United States a trial heavy with threats
and hyperbole kicked off with the
defense we believe that once you hear
those initial presentations the only
conclusion will be that the president
has done absolutely nothing wrong
and that these articles of impeachment
do not begin to approach the standard
required by the Constitution
the president's lawyers were briefed
Democrats opted for breath with a
lengthy argument about process and
partisanship let me be blunt let me be
very blunt right now a great many
perhaps even most Americans do not
believe there will be a fair trial they
don't believe that the Senate will be
impartial they believe that the result
is precooked the president will be
acquitted not because he is innocent he
is not but because the centers will vote
by party and he has the votes there was
no time for weighty evidence instead a
full day dominated by the dispute over
timings and witnesses the Senate's fair
process will draw a sharp contrast with
the unfair and precedent breaking
inquiry that was carried on by the House
of Representatives the McConnell
resolution will result in a rushed trial
with little evidence in the dead of
night if the president is so confident
in his case then why won't he present it
in broad daylight but there was some
light for those who view this as a
cover-up the build-up to this
impeachment trial has been acrimonious
and uncompromising Republicans have
delivered some last-minute concessions
though each side will now get three
rather than two
is to make their case but still only 24
hours in total mr. president would you
try and park jong-hong from testifying
in davos the gesture of a president
who's sick of the scrutiny impeachments
are permanent but bill clinton the last
man to face this process was acquitted
and quickly embraced donald trump could
enjoy a big bounce too and his party is
determined to get this framed and
resolved as quickly as possible
cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington